rejoignez-moi sur patronne pour accéder
à l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour la
FAQ 800000 abonnés et cette FAQ sera le
dernier épisode de la saison puisqu'on
suit on va partir sur une longue pause
estivale il n'aura pas de nouvelles
épisodes pendant l'été à part un épisode
spécial dont je vais vous parler tout à
l'heure alors avant de commencer à
répondre à vos questions quelques
petites annonces donc la première
annonce que je voudrais vous faire c'est
la plus importante et elle concerne vous
vous en doutez ma bande dessinée
philorama donc je vous informe qu'on est
actuellement en train de finaliser la
neuvième histoire sur les dix au total
donc l'avant-dernière ce qui veut dire
qu'il va nous rester l'été pour
s'occuper des retouches des corrections
de la mise en page et donc ce que ça
veut dire c'est que si on ne rencontre
pas d'imprévu d'ici là et bien vous
recevrez votre BD comme prévu avant les
fêtes de fin d'année alors c'est
extrêmement rare que ça se passe aussi
bien dans un projet de ce type de
création de BD surtout quand c'est la
première fois parce qu'il y a toujours
des choses auxquelles on ne pense pas
mais là pour le coup on a assez bien
mené notre barque faut dire qu'on avait
tout planifié jusque dans les moindres
détails et qu'on sait beaucoup
discipliné parce qu'on ne voulait rien
laisser au hasard et donc maintenant
même s'il y a encore quelques paramètres
qui échappent à notre contrôle notamment
les délais d'impression ou les délais
d'expédition tout est en place pour vous
livrer votre bande dessinée comme prévu
avant les fêtes de fin d'année donc ça
c'était la première chose maintenant
deuxième annonce qui concerne ma page
pas très haute alors ça normalement vous
le savez parce que je voulais déjà dit
plusieurs fois sur paréole je publie du
contenu inédit des épisodes spéciaux les
capsules concepts les épisodes retours
les dissertes minutes sur patriote vous
pouvez aussi avoir accès à mes cours de
philosophie en visio que je donne une
fois par mois ainsi qu'aux apéro philos
une fois tous les deux mois et c'est
également sur patronne que je publierai
les épisodes que je ne peux pas publier
sur Youtube et le cas c'est présenté le
mois dernier avec mon épisode sur
shopenhauer et les femmes et donc je
sais que certains parmi vous c'était
mécontent que je publie cet épisode
uniquement sur patreon mais sachez que
c'est quelque chose qui sera peut-être
amené à se reproduire à l'avenir parce
que YouTube ne cesse d'augmenter la
sévérité de son règlement et que
lorsqu'on est créateur de contenu il
faut bien trouver des solutions
alternatives donc moi je voulais déjà
dit mon état d'esprit ce n'est pas du
tout de me plaindre du fonctionnement de
YouTube parce que YouTube est une
entreprise privée donc c'est elle qui
choisit son règlement et que si on n'est
pas content en tant qu'aux créateur de
contenu rien ne nous empêche d'aller sur
une autre plateforme l'ennui c'est que
ces autres plateformes elles ne sont pas
du tout suivies par les spectateurs et
donc ben transférer ma chaîne sur des
plateformes comme Odyssey ou comme
Dailymotion bah ce serait concrètement
prêché dans le désert voilà donc pour
tous ceux qui voudraient être certain
d'avoir accès à l'intégralité de mes
épisodes que ce soit les épisodes
spéciaux où les épisodes censurés et
bien le plus simple est de me rejoindre
directement sur ma page pas très haute
dernière annonce je vous invite tous à
rejoindre sur mon compte Instagram parce
que c'est là que je publie mes
actualités parce que c'est là que je
vous tiens au courant des thèmes des
prochains épisodes et aussi parce que
vous êtes assez nombreux à me demander
parfois d'exprimer mon avis personnel
sur tel ou tel sujet or mes épisodes
c'est pas du tout le lieu pour exprimer
mes opinions personnelles en revanche
sur Instagram il m'arrive de temps à
autre de publier des petits articles des
petits billets d'humeur dans lesquels
pour le coup je donne mon opinion sur
tel ou tel sujet donc si vous voulez
savoir ce que je pense au-delà de ce que
je peux dire dans mes épisodes et bien
le mieux c'est de me rejoindre sur mon
compte Instagram voilà j'en ai terminé
avec les annonces je vais maintenant
passer aux réponses à vos questions
d'ailleurs sachez que parmi toutes les
questions que vous m'avez envoyé il y en
a beaucoup auquel j'avais déjà répondu
dans de précédentes FAQ donc sachez que
si je ne réponds pas à votre question
aujourd'hui il se peut que la réponse se
trouve dans une ancienne FAQ donc j'ai
créé une playlist spécialement dédiée à
mes FAQ et
sachez que toutes mes FAQ sont chapitrés
c'est à dire que vous trouverez un
sommaire qui vous permettra d'arriver
directement aux questions qui vous
intéressent voilà j'en ai assez dit pour
cette introduction qui était beaucoup
trop longue c'est parti première
question comment après en tu
philosophiquement ce grand nombre de
800000 abonnés bah c'est vrai qu'à
partir d'un certain nombre d'abonnés on
ne se rend plus vraiment compte de ce
que ça représente concrètement
maintenant le sentiment que ça m'inspire
c'est évidemment de l'optimisme parce
que j'y vois le signe que la philosophie
touche de plus en plus de monde et ça
évidemment ça rejoint le but de ma
chaîne qui est de m'adresser au plus
grand nombre c'est-à-dire à des
personnes qui de prime abord pourrait
croire que la philosophie n'est pas
faite pour elle or comme je le dis
souvent si les gens ne s'intéressent pas
à la philosophie bah c'est pas la faute
des gens c'est la faute de ceux qui
parlent de philosophie ça veut dire que
les gens qui parlent de philosophie
n'arrivent pas à rendre leurs discipline
intéressant et attractives moi je ne
suis pas pour reprocher aux gens de ne
pas s'intéresser à des choses que
personnellement je trouve importante
parce que pour que les gens aient de
l'intérêt pour quelque chose encore
faut-il que ça t'intéresse soit mis en
avant donc moi je trouve ça assez
incroyable qu'une chaîne de philosophie
a fortiori une chaîne de philosophie qui
ne mise pas du tout sur le spectacle ou
sur le divertissement réunis 800000
personnes donc vous comprenez quand
parallèle quand on pose la question de
savoir ce que je pense de la bêtisant ou
du fait que les gens ne réfléchissent
pas ma réponse c'est que je suis pas
d'accord je trouve ça un peu facile de
reprocher aux gens d'être bête ou de ne
pas réfléchir parce que faut voir aussi
qu'est-ce qui est proposé en termes
d'offres des chaînes de philosophie
grand public en France si on n'a pas des
tonnes il y a Monsieur fille il y a
Cyrus North dans des styles très
différents du mien et donc quand on dit
que les gens ne consomment que du
divertissement ou que du contenu
abrutissant c'est vrai dans une certaine
mesure mais ça vient aussi du fait que
c'est surtout ça qui est proposé sans
compter que quand on dit les gens sont
bêtes pour les autres les gens c'est
vous donc tout ce que je peux vous
encourager à faire c'est de créer
vous-même le contenu que vous
souhaiteriez voir sur internet c'est à
dire de passer du statut de spectateur
au statut de créateur parce que comme le
diras Simone de Beauvoir on ne n'est pas
créateur on le devient et que moi avant
d'être créateur j'ai été spectateur et
que rien ne me prédisposait plus qu'un
autre à passer de l'autre côté donc si
vous voulez que la philosophie que la
littérature que la science règne sur
Internet et ben il y a pas le choix
c'est à vous de faire le boulot question
suivante
penses-tu un jour te lasser de la
philosophie alors si tu poses la
question aujourd'hui ma réponse est non
mais sauf que la vie m'a appris à être
prudent à ne pas trop m'avancer à ne
jamais dire jamais et d'ailleurs ça me
fait penser à une anecdote c'est quand
mon professeur de philosophie en
terminale est parti à la retraite
d'ailleurs je le salue Gérard si tu nous
regardes et quand il est parti à la
retraite je lui ai demandé s'il allait
continuer la philosophie et il m'a
répondu que non parce qu'il pensait en
avoir fait le tour et moi qui était
encore un adolescent un jeune adulte
romantique et idéaliste cette réponse
m'a choquée parce que dans mon esprit on
n'avait jamais fait le tour de la
philosophie et je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui à l'âge de 37 ans et
alors que ça fait cinq ans que j'anime
cette chaîne je n'ai pas l'impression
d'avoir fait le quart du dixième du Tour
de la philosophie après avec le recul je
pense avoir compris une dimension de sa
réponse qui n'était pas du tout de dire
que
vous n'avez plus rien à apprendre de la
vie ou même des autres mais simplement
qu'à partir d'un certain âge l'activité
philosophique avec ce que ça comporte en
termes de lecture de recherche et de
réflexion peut ne plus être le moteur
ultime de notre existence et qu'on peut
avoir atteint une certaine forme de
quiétude d'une certaine forme de
sérénité intérieure de sagesse on peut
le dire qui fait qu'on a plus besoin de
mettre la réflexion au cœur de son
quotidien et peut-être qu'on atteint
jamais vraiment la sagesse mais
peut-être qu'on atteint un stade où on a
juste envie d'être heureux de profiter
de l'instant présent voir que profiter
de l'instant présent c'est peut-être ça
le réel but de la philosophie il y a une
idée qui circule un petit peu naïve et
c'est bien normal qui consiste à croire
que quand on aime la philosophie on
passe chaque seconde de son existence à
philosopher et moi ça m'arrive très
souvent de ne pas faire de philosophie
ça m'arrive très souvent de débrancher
le néocortex parce que la vie ce n'est
pas seulement de la pensée parce que la
vie ce n'est pas seulement
du concept et qu'il y a des tas de
choses dans la vie qui méritent qu'on y
consacre du temps en dehors de la
philosophie question suivante comment
restez-vous motivé à faire ce que vous
faites chaîne Youtube notamment
justement le fait que je n'ai pas encore
fait le tour de la philosophie le fait
que j'ai encore de nombreux territoires
philosophiques à explorer et donc par
voie de conséquence et bien que j'ai
encore beaucoup de choses à vous dire
d'autant que j'ai le double défaut
d'être non seulement assez bavard mais
aussi de ne pas avoir de gêne à me
répéter ce qui veut dire qu'une fois que
j'aurais dit tout ce que j'avais à dire
je peux très bien commencer question
suivante
pourquoi avoir choisi le précepteur
comme pseudo alors j'ai choisi le
précepteur comme pseudonyme parce qu'à
l'époque où j'ai ouvert ma chaîne en
2018 ce devait être non pas une chaîne
de philosophie mais une chaîne de
pédagogie il se trouve qu'à l'époque
j'étais professeur particulier et que
j'avais envie de créer une chaîne pour
diffuser des outils pédagogiques et des
outils d'épistémologie c'est-à-dire de
philosophie de la connaissance et vous
savez que précepteur c'était l'ancien
nom des professeurs particuliers
c'est-à-dire des personnes qui étaient
en charge de l'éducation des enfants
dans les familles nobles et comme à
l'époque je venais de passer une
formation qui s'appelait formation
précepteur dont le but est justement de
professionnaliser le métier de
professeur particulier ben je trouvais
que c'était le nom le plus adapté pour
une chaîne de pédagogie donc finalement
la chaîne est devenue une chaîne de
philosophie mais j'ai quand même gardé
le pseudonyme parce que je me suis dit
que le précepteur c'est un peu chaque
auteur dont je parle dans mes épisodes
chaque auteur dont je parle est un
précepteur parce que chaque auteur dont
je parle à des choses à nous apprendre
question suivante
quel conseil peux-tu donner à ceux qui
hésitent à se lancer sur Youtube et qui
galèrent bah le premier conseil que je
donnerai à quelqu'un qui veut se lancer
sur Youtube bah c'est tout simplement de
commencer c'est à dire de franchir le
pas parce que très souvent on essaye de
projeter mentalement pendant des heures
des semaines voire des mois ce qu'il
faudrait qu'on fasse mais on le fait
jamais quand on se lance dans une
entreprise individuelle il y a un biais
qui consiste à croire qu'on pourrait
planifier intellectuellement la manière
dont ça va se dérouler mais dans les
fait ça marche pas comme ça parce qu'il
y a tout un tas de paramètres qu'on ne
peut pas envisager qu'on ne peut même
pas soupçonner tant qu'on ne sait pas
concrètement lancer un projet individuel
un projet de création c'est un brouillon
a duré indéterminée donc au lieu de
passer des heures à réfléchir à tout ce
qu'on voudrait faire et finalement ne
même pas réussir à en faire la moitié
ben le mieux c'est de commencer et
ensuite petit à petit d'apporter des
améliorations le deuxième conseil que je
peux donner c'est de produire du contenu
qui soit en adéquation non pas avec
l'image que que tu veux renvoyer mais
avec ce qui t'anime profondément moi
j'ai commis cette erreur quand j'ai
lancé ma chaîne alors les erreurs ont
toujours un côté bénéfique parce que ça
nous permet de nous améliorer mais j'ai
voulu créer une image de conseiller
pédagogique qui au fond ne correspond
pas à ce qui me motive véritablement
mais comme je m'étais auto persuadé par
avance que c'était ça que je voulais
faire ben je suis resté un petit peu
enfermé dans ce personnage de conseiller
pédagogique avant de finir par accepter
que ce que je voulais faire c'était pas
ça c'était de la philo parce que c'est
ça qui se produit quand on projette
mentalement ce qu'on veut être c'est
qu'on met beaucoup plus de temps à
accepter le fait qu'on ait fait fausse
route alors que si on commence
directement à faire ce qui nous anime et
ce qui nous correspond ben on perd pas
de temps inutilement donc ça c'est mon
deuxième conseil produire du contenu qui
soit en adéquation avec ce que vous êtes
mon troisième conseil sera plus
technique et ce sera de dire soigner la
forme soyez la forme parce que pour le
spectateur la la forme c'est beaucoup
plus important que ce que vous ne pouvez
le penser quand on se lance dans la
création de contenu on peut avoir cette
enthousiasme cette flamme du débutant
qui consiste à croire que la seule chose
qui compte c'est le fond justement parce
que ce dont on parle nous passionne
parce qu'on en déduit que si ça nous
passionne ça va aussi forcément
passionné les autres et donc on se met à
négliger la forme au motif que
s'attacher à la forme ce serait être
superficiel mais sauf que si ce que vous
proposez est intéressant mais que du
point de vue de la forme ce n'est pas
regardable ou ce n'est pas audible le
spectateur ne va pas rester et ça on
peut pas le reprocher au spectateur
parce qu'on fait tous la même chose moi
par exemple si là tout à coup il se
mettait à y avoir du bruit de fond de la
réverbération et que les balance audio
n'étaient pas gérés ça deviendrait très
vite insupportable et le fond de mon
propos aurait beau être extrêmement
pertinent ou intéressant vos oreilles ne
supporteraient pas c'est comme si vous
parlez de quelque chose d'extrêmement
intéressant avec quelqu'un qui a
mauvaise haleine et qui vous souffle
dans le nez bon ben vous avez beau
trouver que ce qu'il dit est intéressant
il n'empêche que vous allez partir et je
sais pourquoi certains jeunes créateur
sous-estime autant l'importance de la
forme c'est paradoxalement parce qu'ils
sont habitués à consommer du contenu
dans lequel la forme est soignée et que
l'on ne remarque l'importance de la
forme que quand la forme est négligée ce
qui se remarque ce n'est pas le travail
bien fait c'est le travail mal fait ce
qui se remarque ce sont les défauts ce
sont les imperfections donc si on devait
résumer mais trois conseils pour toute
personne qui voudraient se lancer sur
Youtube premièrement se lancer
deuxièmement produire du contenu qui
vous correspondent et troisièmement
soigner la forme question suivante
quelles sont tes chaînes YouTube
préférées je dirais tout d'abord la
chaîne de Gaspard Gaspard g c'est
quelqu'un qui propose des mini
documentaires d'environ 30 minutes sur
des grandes personnalités ou sur des
personnages historiques et j'aime
beaucoup son approche j'aime beaucoup
son ton j'aime beaucoup la fluidité de
ces épisodes je trouve que c'est
quelqu'un qui arrive à nous emmener à
nous immerger dans ce qu'il raconte et
ça je pense que c'est le grand atout des
bons vulgarisateurs c'est qu'ils sont
capables de vous intéresser à des choses
qui de prime abord ne vous intéresse pas
l'histoire de Jeff Bezos ou plutôt
devrais-je dire jeffree Preston commence
le 12 janvier 1964 à Albuquerque il y a
un vrai problème de stockage dans le
monde de l'édition du livre on peut pas
avoir accès à tout ce qu'on veut et
soudain dans l'esprit de Jeff Bezos
l'évidence apparaît Amazon.com en
référence évidemment au plus grand
fleuve du monde qui emporte tout sur son
passage au moins on peut lui enlever ces
ambitions sont bien marquées donc
Gaspard g première chaîne Youtube que je
peux recommander
la deuxième chaîne Youtube que je
citerai c'est celle de cosmos alors
cosmos il se trouve que c'est un
collègue puisque lui aussi parle de
philosophie lui aussi fait des audios et
lui aussi va traiter d'un auteur et de
l'un de ses concepts sur un ton posé sur
un ton calme alors il y a quand même une
différence de style narratif et
d'intonation entre lui et moi mais je
trouve que c'est quelqu'un qui fait de
la bonne vulgarisation et c'est
quelqu'un dont le travail est assez
complémentaire avec le mien il ne sait
ni comment ni pourquoi cette impression
lui est venu mais avec le temps elle
s'est profondément enracinée en lui
jusqu'à devenir sa seule certitude
il ressent de l’écurement non pas
seulement devant les conventions
sociales et ce qu'elles impliquent en
termes d'hypocrisie et de mensonges mais
pour tout ce qui est les êtres et les
objets une troisième chaîne bah écoutez
je vais citer la chaîne de Mozinor parce
que Mozinor c'est le dinosaure de
YouTube et c'est quelqu'un qui m'a
toujours fait rire je me suis jamais
lassé de son humour alors même que son
humour a évolué Bernard Blier je croyais
que vous étiez mort
c'est une citation Maïté non mais quelle
équipe la cuisine à l'armagnac ça va
Alain c'est pas toi qui fracturé la
tirelire
comme ça
je crois qu'on a trouvé une autre
soupape Brigitte se remettre à tout en
place hein c'est un humour qui
fonctionne beaucoup sur moi et qui en
plus c'est amené avec du talent donc bah
ça me donne l'occasion de rendre un
petit hommage à notre chère Mozinor
tu comprends pourquoi le derrière
bon ben finalement c'est insupportable
question suivante
penses-tu sortir de nouveaux concepts de
vidéos sur YouTube la réponse est oui
oui je vais sortir un nouveau format
d'épisode sur ma chaîne il s'agira de
livres audio parce que dans mes épisodes
je parle d'un auteur je parle d'un
concept ou d'un courant de pensée mais
rien ne remplace le texte c'est pour ça
qu'à la fin de mes épisodes il y a
toujours un moment lecture parce que
pour moi ça n'aurait pas de sens de vous
parler de philosophie si je ne vous
renvoyais pas à des textes mais comme je
ne peux pas vous forcer à lire comme je
ne peux pas vous obliger à acheter les
livres des auteurs dont je parle bien je
me suis dit que faire des livres audio
c'était finalement le meilleur moyen de
vous initier directement la lecture de
ces auteurs donc le premier livre audio
que j'ai enregistré sortira cet été
c'est le fameux épisode spécial dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure il s'agira
du manuel d'Épictète alors Epictète
certains d'entre vous le savent c'est un
auteur stoïcien de l'Antiquité et c'est
un personnage assez spécial parce que
Pictet c'était un esclave dans le
stoïcisme on trouve à la fois des
esclaves comme et des empereurs comme
Marc Aurèle et le propre du Manuel des
Pictet c'est que c'est un livre qui se
lit assez facilement qui n'est pas
difficile d'accès et étant donné que ma
chaîne est associée à ton roi raison au
stoïcisme je me suis dit que ce serait
une bonne entrée en matière pour les
livres audio que de commencer avec le
manuel des Pictet mis à part ça il n'y
aura pas de nouveaux formations on va
continuer les épisodes classiques les
audio philo on va également continuer
les entretiens philo même s'il y en a eu
un peu moins cette année et on va
également continuer les portraits philo
je peux d'ores et déjà vous annoncer
qu'à la rentrée vous aurez droit à un
portrait philo sur le personnage de
Michael korleon question suivante
est-ce que tu utilises les intelligences
artificielles pour la réalisation de ton
contenu la réponse est NON je n'utilise
pas les intelligences artificielles pour
réaliser mon contenu et quand tu dis
intelligence artificielle je pense que
tu fais référence à
GPT je l'ai utilisé pour voir ce qu'il
avait dans le ventre et forcément que
j'ai été déçu j'ai été déçu parce que
j'ai repéré des erreurs flagrantes j'ai
repéré des anachronismes j'ai repéré des
confusions entre les auteurs et ça m'a
fait dire que cette technologie aussi
prometteuse soit elle est encore loin
d'être au point alors je ne doute pas
que d'ici quelques mois ou d'ici
quelques années tchat GPT ce sera
amélioré et que ce sera même devenu une
référence en termes de fiabilité des
ressources mais sauf qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas encore le cas et si je devais
utiliser chat GPT pour me faciliter le
travail ben je pense que ça m'amènerait
à commettre quelques belles erreurs
alors il se trouve que sur patréon
récemment on organisait un apérophylo
sur la question des intelligences
artificielles et notamment sur la
question de savoir si les intelligences
artificielles allaient être en mesure de
remplacer les professeurs de philosophie
et ma conclusion provisoire parce que je
reste prudent mais ma conclusion c'est
qu'à ce jour l'intelligence artificielle
ne peut pas remplacer un professeur de
philosophie parce que l'intelligence
artificielle est incapable de produire
ou de reproduire quelque chose qui est
indispensable à l'acte de transmission
qui est l'énergie quand on écoute
quelqu'un on n'écoute pas seulement un
débit d'information on écoute une voix
on écoute un récit on écoute une énergie
chaque GPS sera sans doute bientôt
capable de savoir infiniment plus de
choses que moi mais aussi de les
restituer de manière infiniment plus
claire mais tchat gpté ne sera pas
capable de véhiculer cette énergie qui
est l'enthousiasme donc c'est pour ça
que je ne me sens pas du tout
menacé par l'intelligence artificielle
mais le jour où l'intelligence
artificielle sera capable de me
remplacer et bien dans ce cas là je
ferai autre chose question suivante
à quel âge la philosophie a-t-elle
commencé à vous intéresser la
philosophie a commencé à m'intéresser
lorsque j'étais à la maternelle donc
j'avais quatre ou cinq ans et le premier
questionnement philosophique que je me
suis posé c'était la question de Dieu
question suivante
quelle est la place de la philosophie
dans vos réflexions quotidiennes quelles
sont les bénéfices d'avoir étudié la
philosophie au quotidien alors ça c'est
une question dont la réponse est
tellement évidente pour moi qu'elle en
devient difficile à traduire en mot pour
moi la philosophie c'est un rapport au
monde c'est un rapport aux autres et un
rapport à soi et si je devais définir ce
qu'est la philosophie pour moi je dirais
que c'est un effort permanent vers la
compréhension donc la philosophie m'aide
au quotidien au sens où j'ai toujours
envie de comprendre ce qui arrive vous
savez dans la vie quotidienne il arrive
très fréquemment qu'on se retrouve dans
des situations dont on ne comprend pas
le sens ou qu'on parle avec des
personnes avec qui on n'est pas du tout
d'accord la philosophie c'est ce à
m'encourager à comprendre le sens de ce
qui arrive et à comprendre comment pense
celui avec qui je ne suis pas d'accord
parce qu'on va pas se mentir quand on se
retrouve dans des situations dont on ne
comprend pas le sens notre réflexe
premier c'est de se dire ça n'a pas de
sens lorsqu'on se retrouve face à une
personne avec qui on n'est pas d'accord
notre réflexe premier c'est de se dire
cette personne a tort moi la philosophie
c'est ce qui me pousse à me dire si
cette situation arrive c'est qu'il y a
une raison si cette personne pense ce
qu'elle pense c'est qu'il y a une raison
donc si je devais résumer je dirais que
la philosophie c'est ce qui permet
d'entrer en empathie avec le monde et
avec les autres question suivante
avec tes amis ta famille te sens-tu
libre de philosopher autant que tu
aimerais ou te limite tu alors je dirais
pas que je me limite mais plutôt que je
m'adapte et c'est pas la même chose se
limiter ça signifie qu'on fait un effort
de retenue de répression ce qui est pas
du tout mon cas en revanche je m'adapte
parce que quand je passe du temps avec
mes amis le but c'est de passer un
moment léger un moment de bonne humeur
un moment de détente et la philosophie
n'a pas toujours sa place dans ces
moments-là maintenant ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est de parler philosophie
sans qu'on s'en aperçoive aborder des
sujets abordés des questions sous un
angle philosophique mais sans dire qu'on
fait de la philosophie parce que la
philosophie c'est comme la sexualité dès
qu'on prononce le mot ça gâche tout il y
a des choses qui sont faites pour avoir
lieu et pas pour être dites donc
finalement c'est ça ma conception de la
philosophie faire quelque chose sans
avoir besoin de le dire question
suivante
salut j'ai 14 ans j'ai déjà lu des
livres de philo penses-tu qu'à cet âge
là je puisse bien penser alors c'est
vrai que statistiquement à 14 ans on
s'intéresse assez peu à la philosophie
parce que la philosophie ça reste de
l'abstraction or à 14 ans on est en
pleine adolescence on est en pleine
ébullition et en plein éveil sur le
monde et donc on préfère le concret
maintenant c'est à 14 ans tu
t'intéresses déjà la philosophie je ne
peux que t'encourager à continuer dans
ce sens en te disant de garder à
l'esprit que tes évidences d'aujourd'hui
sont tes questionnements de demain
question suivante
bonjour tu aimerais faire des
conférences en présentiel un jour alors
on m'a déjà proposé à de nombreuses
reprises de faire des conférences en
présentiel et je dois admettre que la
plupart du temps je décline les
invitations pour une raison toute bête
qui est que quand je suis dans mon
bureau et que j'enregistre un nouvel
épisode je sais que je vais toucher un
public infiniment plus nombreux que si
je me déplace physiquement pour une
conférence alors oui ça peut paraître
une vision un peu utilitariste de la
transmission mais j'estime que pour
l'instant je suis beaucoup plus utile
dans ce rôle de vulgarisateur sur
Youtube plutôt que dans un rôle de
conférencier qui sera peut-être le bien
plus tard mais pour l'instant je préfère
continuer dans mon rôle de conférencier
internautique question suivante
quel cours en philosophique te
correspond le plus quel mouvement de
pensée philosophe préfères-tu bon ben ça
vous a déjà nombreux à le savoir le
mouvement philosophique dans lequel je
me reconnais le plus c'est le stoïcisme
le stoïcisme qui prescrit de ne se
concentrer que sur ce qui dépend de nous
et de ne pas être affecté par ce qui ne
dépend pas de nous une pensée
extrêmement rationnelle extrêmement
logique mais en même temps une pensée
accessible à l'être humain puisque
l'être humain est doté d'une raison je
ne considère pas du tout le stoïcisme
comme une pensée inhumaine comme une
pensée de l'indifférence aux autres je
pense que le stoïcisme à cette vertu qui
est de nous ramener à la réalité et
notamment à cette réalité qui ne nous
appartient pas de réaliser l'impossible
je vous disais tout à l'heure il y a des
situations de la vie où notre réflexe
premier c'est de dire c'est pas normal
c'est pas normal sous-entendu ça ne
devrait pas arriver et beaucoup de
personnes se rendent malades face à des
situations dont on estime qu'elle ne
devrait pas arriver le stoïcisme c'est
ce qui permet de comprendre que quand
quelque chose arrive il y a des raisons
pour lesquelles ça arrive et que donc ça
ne sert à rien d'être dans le déni ou
dans le rejet de la réalité et pour vous
prouver à quel point je suis
authentiquement stoïcien bien je vais
vous mettre dans la confidence sachez
que cette FAQ que je suis en train
d'enregistrer j'ai commencé à
l'enregistrer ce matin et au bout d'une
heure trente d'enregistrement je me suis
rendu compte que mon micro n'était pas
branché et à ce moment là j'ai eu la
réponse à la question qu'est-ce que le
stoïcisme le stoïcisme c'est pouvoir
enregistrer une FAQ pendant 1h30 se
rendre compte que son micro n'était pas
branché et ne pas tout casser le
stoïcisme c'est accepter accepter parce
que je ne peux pas revenir en arrière
accepté parce que m’énerver ne changera
rien ou plutôt si je peux changer
quelque chose je peux ajouter de
l'énervement à la frustration quand je
suis tout seul dans mon bureau en train
d'enregistrer ma FAQ qui est-ce que je
pénalise par mon énervement par moi-même
donc le stoïcisme c'est cette capacité à
mettre sa vie intérieure en conformité
avec la raison je vous ferai
prochainement un épisode spécial sur le
stoïcisme un épisode témoignage dans
lequel je vous expliquerai en quoi le
stoïcisme a changé ma vie en revanche
même si le mouvement philosophique dans
lequel je me reconnais le plus c'est le
stoïcisme mon philosophe favori reste
égale question suivante pourquoi Eagle
est en philosophe favori je crois que je
suis sur écoute et quel est mon
philosophe favori parce que Hegel a
théorisé la dialectique c'est-à-dire le
progrès par la contradiction le fait
qu'on progresse que par la
reconnaissance de ses erreurs et que
reconnaître ses erreurs n'est pas une
faiblesse mais une force question
suivante
qu'est-ce qui te rend le plus heureux
des profiteroles au chocolat avec un
verre de cognac avoir des connaissances
profondes en philosophie est-il un
obstacle au bonheur simple en quelque
sorte oui oui parce que quand on plonge
dans la philosophie et quand on est un
amoureux du raisonnement on peut avoir
tendance à tourner en boucle dans ses
raisonnements de manière incessante j'ai
fait un épisode il y a quelques années
du temps où le précepteur était encore
une chaîne de pédagogie dans lequel je
parlais de la pensée compulsive la
pensée compulsive c'est l'incapacité que
nous avons parfois à interrompre le film
de nos réflexions c'est le fait d'être
tout le temps dans la projection mentale
dans la construction de scénarios
intellectuels ce qui fait qu'à la fin on
ne réfléchit plus pour résoudre des
problèmes mais pour le plaisir d'avoir
des problèmes à résoudre mais sauf que
ça ça peut être extrêmement énergivore
et générateur de souffrance quand on est
dans l'impossibilité
d'interrompre le fil de sa pensée on
souffre et si je dis tout ça c'est parce
que très souvent on voit la philosophie
comme une discipline de complexification
de la réalité c'est à dire que parfois
quand les réponses sont trop simples on
les repousse parce qu'on estime qu'elles
ne sont pas dignes mais ça c'est le
contraire de l'intelligence puisque
justement l'intelligence sert à résoudre
quand la pensée n'est plus mise au
service de la résolution de problèmes
mais de la création de problèmes c'est
qu'il y a un problème donc oui je dirais
qu'il y a une fâcheuse tendance chez
certaines personnes qui pratiquent la
philosophie à être hermétique aux choses
simples et au bonheur simple question
suivante
est-ce qu'on peut accepter tout opinion
on peut accepter toutes les opinions à
partir du moment où on fait l'effort de
comprendre pourquoi ces opinions
existent accepter toutes les opinions ce
n'est pas du relativisme ce n'est pas
dire que toutes les opinions se valent
c'est simplement reconnaître une opinion
comme existante et donc se poser la
question du pourquoi de son existence
j'ai donné un cours récemment sur la
question de savoir s'il fallait
respecter toutes les opinions et ce qui
est amusant c'est que ce qui ressort
très souvent c'est que on est prêt à
respecter toutes les opinions du moment
qu'elle ne contredisent pas nos propres
opinions la question du respect des
opinions ne se poser réellement que
quand on est confronté à une opinion qui
nous choque parce qu'au fond qu'est-ce
qui nous dérange vraiment dans une
opinion est-ce que c'est le fait qu'elle
soit fausse est-ce que c'est le fait
qu'elle soit objectivement dangereuse ou
est-ce que c'est le fait qu'elle
éveillons-nous des émotions et des
affects qui nous déplaisent et la
question qui se pose ensuite c'est si on
doit pas accepter toutes les opinions
comment doit-on traiter les opinions
inacceptables est-ce qu'on doit les
censurer est-ce qu'on doit les condamner
comme disait bossués on doit accepter
les conséquences de ce dont on chérit
les causes si vous êtes pour la liberté
d'expression mais contre l'expression de
certaines opinions bah c'est peut-être
que le problème vient de vous on peut
être contre l'expression de certaines
opinions mais dans ce cas-là il faut le
dire il faut l'assumer et moi je ne suis
pas pour qu'on empêche les gens de
s'exprimer je suis pour qu'on encourage
les gens à s'exprimer pour pouvoir
identifier leurs pensées parce que si
les personnes disent exactement ce
qu'elle pense on aura plus besoin de
deviner leurs arrières pensées donc
acceptons le débat contradictoire
acceptons le débat rationnel y compris
avec des opinions qui nous choquent et
arrêtons d'infantiliser la masse comme
si les gens étaient incapables d'esprit
critique question suivante
peut-on être convaincu par deux pensées
ou idées contradictoires bien sûr qu'on
peut être convaincu par deux pensées
contradictoires et c'est pas un problème
il y a beaucoup de gens qui pensent que
avoir des opinions ça signifie être
militant mais on peut avoir des opinions
et ne pas chercher à les imposer aux
autres ou à la société le biais du
militant c'est de considérer que par ce
qu'on est soi-même militant les autres
le seraient aussi être convaincu par
deux pensées contradictoires savoir
faire un travail qui est extrêmement
précieux en philosophie qui est la
translation du point de vue être capable
de se décentrer de son propre point de
vue être capable d'épouser la conscience
et le point de vue de l'autre parce que
encore une fois l'opinion de l'autre
elle a une raison d'être la question
c'est de savoir pourquoi l'autre pense
ce qu'il pense qu'est-ce qu'il a à
m'apporter pour enrichir mon point de
vue et qu'est-ce que j'ai à lui apporter
pour enrichir le sien donc le crime de
mauvaise pensée c'est très bien pour les
romans d'Orwell mais en philosophie ça
n'existe pas question suivante
que penses-tu de la politique de nos
jours je pense que la politique est un
spectacle que je refuse de participer à
ce spectacle que les militants
politiques sont très souvent de jeunes
gens en quête d'un supplément d'âme
qu'ils épousent la politique comme au
19e siècle on épousait la religion pour
donner un sens à leur vie je pense que
la politique c'est le lieu du dogmatisme
de l'arrogance et de l'étroitesse
d'esprit que la politique pourrit la
pensée que la politique pourrit la
réflexion honnête parce qu'on ne pense
plus en termes d'idées on ne pense plus
en termes de vrai on pense en termes de
lignes et on pense en termes
d'appartenance à un camp je pense que la
politique n'est que le bras armé de
l'économie qu'on pourra s'échapper tant
qu'on voudra sur les sujets politiques
rien ne changera tant qu'on restera dans
un système capitaliste je pense que les
électeurs sont les vaches à lait d'un
système qui a besoin de notre
consentement par les urnes que croire
que le changement viendra de la classe
politique est une illusion mortifère je
pense que la politique est un piège et
que la vie est trop courte pour
s'intéresser à la politique question
suivante
conseilleriez-vous à une personne très
influençable de l'irn Nietzsche je
conseillerais à tout le monde de lire
Nietzsche je ne catégorise pas
l'humanité entre les gens influençables
et les gens qui le sont pas c'est vrai
qu'il y a des gens influençables mais je
ne leur jette pas la pierre parce qu'en
face il y a des gens extrêmement
dogmatiques et les gens influençables
ont au moins cette vertu par rapport au
dogmatique qui est d'écouter ce qu'on
leur dit je suis un militant de l'esprit
critique je suis pour que tout le monde
remette en cause ce qui est affirmé
comme vrai mais je ne suis pas pour
cacher des oeuvres ou pour cacher des
propos aux uns ou aux autres parce qu'il
serait influençable à partir du moment
où vous êtes adulte et doté d'une raison
je m'adresse à vous comme à une personne
qui possède un esprit critique question
suivante
dans quelle mesure pourrais-tu te
définir comme un conservateur et dans
quelle mesure pourrais-tu au contraire
te définir comme un progressiste alors
c'est très facile je dirais que je suis
progressiste sur la question sociale
plus exactement sur la question
socio-économique puisque aujourd'hui le
mot social est devenu une sorte de
fourre-tout donc pour le dire de la
manière la plus claire possible je suis
dans le camp des travailleurs et c'est
justement parce que je suis dans le camp
des travailleurs que je milite pour la
notion de mérite parce que j'estime
qu'un ouvrier ou qu'une femme qui se
lève à 6h du matin pour aller faire des
ménages à infiniment plus de mérite car
entier ou qu'un trader je suis pour le
mérite précisément parce que ce n'est
pas la méritocratie qui est appliquée
c'est le règne du privilège or le mérite
c'est l'inverse du privilège mais il
semblerait que le mérite soit devenu un
concept de droite alors moi j'aimerais
qu'on m'explique comment le mérite peut
être un concept de droite quand on
défend la cause des travailleurs
c'est-à-dire la cause de ce à qui
revient le mérite à croire que de gauche
ce n'est plus défendre les travailleurs
mais ces défendre le droit à la paresse
moi si je suis progressiste sur le plan
social c'est justement parce que je
considère que le travailleur a plus de
mérite que le paresseux et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs en grande partie je pense que
les travailleurs ne votent plus à gauche
parce que le mérite n'est plus défendu
et pour aller plus loin je pense que le
problème c'est le capitalisme je pense
que le capitalisme est un système qui
porte en lui le germe de l'inégalité et
de l'injustice et que croire qu'on
combat le capitalisme à travers un
engagement progressiste sur la question
sociétale et culturelle c'est un leur et
du coup ça m'amène à la deuxième partie
de la question sur quel plan est-ce que
je me définirais davantage comme
conservateur je me définirai davantage
comme conservateur sur le plan de
l'éducation je pense que l'éducation
c'est en grande partie l'inculation des
principes par lesquels un enfant devient
un individu libre et responsable que
dans une société régie par des cadres on
nette pas un enfant en l'élevant sans
cadre et je dirais que je suis
conservateur sur la question de la
délinquance et de la criminalité parce
que je suis pour l'application de la loi
question suivante
que penses-tu du scientisme à savoir
cette religion qui tend à faire de la
science un Dieu alors ça c'est
évidemment un sujet qui m'intéresse
énormément la question du scientisme ou
du dogmatisme scientifique c'est-à-dire
qu'on a l'habitude de présenter la
science comme une anti-religion et moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de constater
que au sein de la communauté
scientifique il y a des attitudes et des
modes de pensée qui relèvent typiquement
de la religion le fait de refuser de
mettre en doute le dogme dominant le
fait de considérer la sainte méthode
comme infaillible le fait aussi de
militer pour la propagation de la
science comme certains militent pour la
Propagation de la Foi en fait si on sort
de cette dichotomie un peu superficielle
entre science et religions ben on va
s'apercevoir qu'il y a de nombreux
points communs et moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse justement parce que ça
contredit l'évidence on a pu constater
dans les dernières semaines et les
derniers mois à quel point le fait de se
prévaloir de la science de la méthode
scientifique et de l'esprit critique ne
prémunissez pas contre les comportements
fanatiques et moi ma position c'est que
la science comme la politique d'ailleurs
est devenue un nouveau lieu
d'investissement du sacré c'est à dire
que la religion s'est effondrée le
christianisme et donc il faut réinvestir
le sacré par d'autres voix parce que le
sacré est un besoin fondamental de
l'être humain et parce que quand la
religion n'a surplus son rôle de
réceptacle de la foi il faut en trouver
de nouveau c'est pour ça que pour moi la
religion ce n'est pas tant une affaire
de contenu de nos croyances mais de
modalités de nos croyances autrement dit
est-ce qu'on croit de manière aveugle et
dogmatique ou de manière raisonnée donc
le scientisme c'est la volonté de faire
de la science le nouveau pôle de la
croyance universelle et c'est ce qui
fait que si la science c'est la lumière
le scientisme c'est l'obscurantisme
question suivante
comment expliquer à quelqu'un que le
concept populaire de karma c'est du
bullshit bien écoute pour ma part je ne
considère pas que le concept de karma
soit du bullshit alors évidemment tout
dépend de ce qu'on appelle le karma mais
si c'est l'idée que l'on récolte ce que
l'on sème je pense que le karma est une
notion tout à fait valide je veux dire
par là que si on passe son temps à
dénigrer les autres si on passe son
temps à critiquer à offenser ou à
injurier il ne faut pas s'étonner si un
jour toutes les personnes qu'on a
blessées se coalisent contre nous c'est
à dire que récolter ce que l'on sème ça
ne fait pas appel à des forces mystiques
ça fait appel à des forces matérielles
si vous causez du tort à des gens ces
gens là vont vouloir se venger et
admettons que vous soyez dans une
situation de pouvoir une situation de
succès ou de domination et que vous en
profitez pour mépriser les personnes que
vous jugez inférieur vous allez vous
sentir tout puissant précisément parce
que ces personnes là ne peuvent pas mais
supposer qu'un jour vous commettiez un
faux pas ou qu'une personne vous
trahisse ou que vous perdiez l'un de vos
privilèges ce jour-là vous devenez
vulnérable plus vous ferez du mal autour
de vous plus vous devez vous attendre à
ce que ce mal réagisse donc pour moi le
karma ce n'est pas simplement une
affaire de malchance une affaire de
hasard c'est une affaire de conséquence
issues des causes dont vous êtes à
l'origine et bien entendu qu'il y a des
personnes qui font du mal pendant des
années pendant des décennies et qui ne
seront jamais punies mais premièrement
c'est assez rare d'échapper aux
conséquences de nos actes pendant toute
notre vie et deuxièmement ça ne sert à
rien de provoquer le destin question
suivante
on veut la philosophie de Forrest Gump
message de Rémi GAILLARD bien figure-toi
Rémy que la philosophie de Forrest Gump
sa trotte dans ma tête mais fais
attention que je ne décide pas de faire
un épisode spécial sur toi à quand une
vidéo sur la philosophie franc-maçonne
pour compléter votre vidéo sur les
lumières ça se fera parce que la
franc-maçonnerie c'est évidemment une
institution qui nourrit énormément les
fantasmes et les théories mais au-delà
de tout ça la franc-maçonnerie c'est une
philosophie c'est même une idéologie et
c'est une idéologie qui a des
ramifications dans la philosophie des
Lumières au XVIIIe siècle donc tôt ou
tard j'aborderai la question de la
franc-maçonnerie sur ma chaîne question
suivante bonjour as-tu lu le livre
l'éveil des consciences de Frédéric
Delavier pourras-tu faire une vidéo
dessus alors oui j'ai lu l'éveil des
conscience de Frédéric Delavier et lui
consacrer un épisode et bah pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas parce que derrière le
personnage un petit peu excentrique de
Frédéric Delavier ancien powerlifter
ancien athlète de force bah en fait il y
a une vision du monde il y a une vision
des relations humaines qui méritent
qu'on s'y intéressent parce que moi ce
que je remarque c'est que Frédéric
Delavier est très souvent moqué par des
personnes qui n'ont seulement n'ont pas
lu son livre mais qui en plus n'ont pas
la moitié de ses connaissances ni le
quart de son acuité intellectuelle alors
oui c'est facile de se moquer parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui fait des vidéos sans
rentrer dans les codes de la modernité
youtubeuse c'est quelqu'un qui a un
style et une manière d'être un peu
abrupte qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
rencontrer dans les cafés littéraires
mais moi le mépris de classe qui
consiste à discréditer la pensée de
quelqu'un sous prétexte qu'il a fait de
la musculation vous vous doutez bien que
j'accorde pas beaucoup de valeur donc
que nous propose Frédéric Delavier dans
son livre il nous propose une lecture de
l'évolution humaine sous l'angle des
rapports énergétiques autrement dit il
adopte un point de vue naturaliste voire
animal de la condition humaine et donc
pour lui et c'est ça que je trouve
vraiment intéressant dans son livre
c'est que nos comportements
socioculturels seraient en fait
l'expression et le prolongement de notre
lutte pour l'énergie parce que c'est
vrai qu'on est très pro à dire que
l'homme est un animal comme les autres
ça ça pose pas de problème mais
curieusement ça commence à poser
problème quand on rentre dans l'analyse
des comportements humains autrement dit
quand on détecte dans notre comportement
humain des traces de notre comportement
animal parce qu'évidemment les analyses
de Frédéric Delavier vont complètement à
l'encontre de tous les principes de
l'inclusivité Frédéric Delavier
considère qu'il y a des différences
entre ethnie qui sont le fruit de
l'adaptation à un milieu géographique
Frédéric Delavier considère qu'il y a
des différences entre les hommes et les
femmes qui sont le fruit de la
différence de sélection des aptitudes
par l'évolution et donc c'est ça
finalement le comble de la critique
moderne des idées c'est qu'au lieu de se
dire qu'on a à faire un NAT qui analyse
l'humanité sous l'angle biologique sous
l'angle de l'évolution et ben en fait on
aurait affaire à un sexiste ou un
raciste qui dit qu'il y a des
différences entre les gens mais ça c'est
une critique idéologique de sa pensée
quand les chimpanzés se font la guerre
pour le pouvoir et l'accès aux femelles
on dit pas que ces misogynes l'évolution
ne se pose pas de question idéologique
et pour vous dire à quel point ça va
loin il y a quelques mois il y a une
émission qui est passée en live sur
YouTube dans laquelle Frédéric Delavier
était confronté à l'un de ses
contradicteurs et tenter d'expliquer la
vulnérabilité physique des femmes durant
la préhistoire et ce qu'il disait c'est
que du fait que les femmes portaient les
enfants elle n'avaient pas la capacité
de se défendre physiquement contre un
agresseur et là son contradicteur lui a
répondu mais pourquoi ce serait aux
femmes de porter les enfants avec un
petit dans les bras qui peut pas
survivre
j'ai de rester près des arbres prêt à
monter avec nous est-ce que vous êtes
sûrs dans les bras des hommes en fait
pourquoi les petits étaient dans les
bras des femmes c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
on a eu des roches stéréotypées sexistes
avant la civilisation et après ça il y a
eu un petit silence gêné après quoi
Frédéric delavie a répondu elle les
nourrissent elles peuvent pas bah oui
parce que jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'était les femmes qui allaitaient les
enfants le lait maternel ça se trouvait
pas à la pharmacie et pour moi cette
scène elle dit absolument tout parce
qu'elle montre à quel point l'idéologie
peut nous rendre aveugle sur la réalité
biologique on peut retrouver quand même
vite Mor sexuel qui montre que les
autres que les mâles sont plus massifs
beaucoup plus massifs et que les
femelles et ça c'est du sexisme Cédric
et quand l'idéologie nous rend aveugle
sur la réalité c'est le début de la
malhonnêteté et là certains répondront
oui mais aujourd'hui on en est plus là
mais évidemment qu'aujourd'hui on en est
plus là mais sauf qu'on ne tire pas un
trait sur des millions d'années
d'évolution juste en disant c'est
stigmatisant et pareil quand Frédéric
Delavier explique que ce qu'on appelle
la beauté c'est en fait tout ce qui va
être lié au signe de fertilité et
d'optimisation de la vie ben c'est
exactement ce que disait shopenhauer au
19e siècle est-ce que la beauté la
beauté la bonne conformation
les hommes sont majoritairement les
mâles de notre espèce sont
majoritairement
attirés par les femelles les femmes si
tu veux je parle en espèces les femmes
jeunes et fécondes et kochopenhauer dit
ça on le traite pas de philosophe de
caniveau on édite ses œuvres au presse
universitaire de France Frédéric delavie
c'est quelqu'un qui a un regard
totalement défocalisé sur l'être humain
c'est à dire que il ne met pas de
jugement de valeur il ne met pas
d'affect ou d'émotions il analyse il y a
des pathogènes respiratoires au nord qui
force les femmes à rester près du foyer
pour pas qu'il y ait une multiplication
de certains pathogènes dans les bronches
qui développent à certaines températures
les femmes vont chercher la nourriture
pour des raisons pathologies et donc moi
c'est pour ça que je soutiens Frédéric
Delavier et que je prône la lecture de
son livre contre toutes les tentatives
d'idéologie sont propos alors oui
peut-être que quand vous allez lire son
livre parfois vous allez tiquer vous
allez avoir un petit froncement de
sourcils parce que vous allez lire des
choses qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de lire
aujourd'hui mais la philosophie et la
réflexion ce n'est pas une question de
savoir si un livre est confortable
c'est-à-dire s'il conforte nos opinions
la question c'est de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on peut en extraire qu'est-ce qu'on
prend en extraire en termes de
compréhension du monde et des autres et
d'ailleurs je partage l'une des idées
fondamentales de Frédéric Delavier à
propos de l'être humain à savoir que
l'être humain c'est le lieu d'un conflit
intérieur permanent entre l'instinct et
la conscience entre la pulsion et la
raison et Frédéric Delavier ne dit pas
du tout qu'il faut se comporter comme
des animaux instinctifs au contraire il
dit qu'il faut comprendre notre instinct
qu'il faut prendre notre animalité pour
mieux nous en affranchir on est formaté
par des vieilles programmations qui bien
sûr non souvent
lieux de prendre ce que prune Frédéric
Delavier c'est la compréhension de soi
au service de la compréhension des
autres et la compréhension des autres au
service de l'amour des autres question
suivante bonjour Charles selon toi
pourquoi la plupart des gens déclarent
que la naissance de leur enfant et le
plus beau jour de leur vie lorsqu'on
leur pose la question bah je dirais que
ça vient du fait que la naissance de
notre enfant c'est symboliquement mettre
un pied dans l'immortalité avoir un
enfant c'est transmettre ses gènes
autrement dit c'est se transmettre
soi-même à travers un autre donc on peut
dire que quand on donne naissance on se
donne une renaissance il y a quelque
chose de très égoïste dans le fait
d'avoir un enfant c'est à dire dans le
fait de se reproduire donc de se
produire à nouveau c'est à dire qu'avoir
un enfant c'est comme réexister mais de
manière externalisée et c'est pour ça
que généralement les parents sont prêts
à se sacrifier pour leur enfant parce
que leur enfant c'est eux en plus jeunes
et puis aussi quelque chose d'assez
mystérieux pour ne pas dire
domestiques dans le fait de donner
naissance parce que on parle d'un acte
créateur donc c'est très démiurgique
d'avoir un enfant parce que c'est créer
la vie or la vie reste une énigme donc
je dirais que c'est pour toutes ces
raisons là qui sont évidemment
inconscientes dans notre esprit que la
naissance de notre enfant peut être
considéré comme le plus beau jour de
notre vie question suivante
selon toi l'homme est en majorité
façonné par sa nature ou par sa culture
je répondrai que c'est les deux c'est
une combinaison des deux parce que la
culture c'est l'extension de la nature
mais en même temps la nature pure
n'existe pas c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où on a créé le premier outil et
le premier routier était sans doute un
objet qu'on a détourné de sa fonction
initiale à partir de là on était déjà
dans la culture et la culture ce n'est
pas ce qui s'oppose à la nature la
culture c'est la transformation par
l'homme de la nature et ça rejoint ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure avec
Frédéric Delavier c'est-à-dire que si on
considère l'être humain comme un être
purement culturel si on s'interdit de le
considérer aussi comme un être naturel
c'est-à-dire comme un être biologique
animal et bien on s'interdit de
comprendre énormément de choses sur
l'expression culturelle de sa nature et
moi j'irai même encore plus loin je
dirais que la nature de l'homme c'est sa
culture c'est à dire que si on devait
trouver un critère qui distingue l'être
humain des autres animaux ce critère
c'est la culture c'est à dire la
capacité à transformer le monde la
capacité à transmettre un héritage à
transmettre un patrimoine et c'est cette
capacité de transmission qui permet
l'évolution qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on
peut dire que nous sommes des êtres
évolués bah c'est justement le fait que
pendant des millions d'années nous avons
reçu un héritage de la part de la
génération précédente qui nous a permis
à chaque fois d'aller un peu plus loin
dans la maîtrise de la nature et dans sa
compréhension donc pour moi la nature et
la culture sont totalement
indissociables et il me paraît aussi
aberrant de réduire l'homme à sa nature
que de le réduire à sa culture question
suivante
pourquoi ne vivons-nous pas nu parce que
les organes reproducteurs les organes
sexuels sont les organes de notre
animalité or la culture ce qui fait le
propre de l'être humain c'est
précisément cet arrachement à notre
nature cet arrachement à notre animalité
et donc recouvrir les organes
reproducteurs c'est une manière
d'oublier que nous sommes avant tout des
animaux alors évidemment il y a d'autres
paramètres qui entre en jeu notamment
l'hygiène et la protection vis-à-vis des
infections mais symboliquement je dirais
que si l'être humain se couvre il se
couvre et se découvre c'est parce qu'il
recouvre la partie la moins digne la
moins noble de sa constitution physique
à savoir ces organes reproducteurs et
d'ailleurs à contrario ce sont souvent
les yeux la partie du corps qui est
valorisée culturellement parce que les
yeux c'est la partie du corps humain qui
permet l'expression des émotions des
sentiments et qui permet l'interaction
avec l'autre donc on peut dire que les
organes sexuels sont les organes de la
reproduction
tandis que les yeux sont les organes de
la communication la reproduction étant
le processus de duplication de soi
tandis que la communication c'est le
processus d'échange avec l'autre
question suivante as-tu une fois une
croyance ou quelque chose qui te guide
spirituellement je crois dans la
possibilité pour l'être humain de
s'améliorer
pourquoi la majorité des êtres humains
sont angoissés par l'absence de cadres
parce qu'il existe quelque chose dans
l'univers qui s'appelle le chaos et que
le meilleur moyen de se prémunir contre
le chaos c'est l'ordre il y a un livre
que je peux vous recommander c'est le
livre de Jordan Peterson qui s'appelle
12 règles pour une vie alors le titre
est un peu trompeur parce que ça donne
l'impression que c'est un livre de
développement personnel mais le
sous-titre est beaucoup plus parlant le
sous-titre c'est sortir du chaos et ce
qui explique Jordan Peterson c'est que
toute la culture humaine s'est
construite sur l'angoisse du chaos parce
que le chaos c'est l'absence de sens et
l'absence de sens c'est la mort ce qu'on
appelle les cadres ce qu'on appelle les
règles c'est ce qui vient donner du sens
à notre existence et ce sens il est
nécessaire pour oublier que l'existence
en elle-même n'a pas de sens et donc là
évidemment on retrouve l'analyse de
Nietzsche sur la différence entre le
dionysiaque et la polynien on retrouve
l'analyse de Schopenhauer sur la volonté
et la représentation c'est à dire sur le
fait que le son c'est peut-être une
illusion une illusion humaine mais c'est
une illusion qui permet de survivre
question suivante quel est selon vous la
question philosophique la plus
vertigineuse justement c'est la question
du sens c'est la question de savoir si
le sens est une pure invention humaine
ou si c'est quelque chose qui existe
indépendamment de l'esprit humain et
même dans le cas où le sens serait une
pure invention humaine bah le fait est
qu'il existe à travers nous moi souvent
je m'interroge sur la pertinence qu'il y
a au dualisme c'est-à-dire au fait de
séparer l'esprit de la matière je disais
tout à l'heure que le fait de recouvrir
ses organes reproducteurs ça avait à la
fois une fonction symbolique le fait de
s'arracher à notre animalité et une
fonction pratique le fait de limiter les
infections et mon questionnement c'est
de savoir dans quelle mesure la fonction
symbolique et la fonction pratique ne
sont pas une seule et même fonction
comme si le symbolique était
l'idéalisation du pratique et le
pratique la concrétisation du symbolique
et ce qui rend cette question
vertigineuse pour le coup c'est
justement le fait qu'il soit impossible
de dissocier les deux dimensions parce
que la nature est ainsi faite que nous
sommes des êtres conscients incarnés
c'est-à-dire que l'esprit et la matière
sont liés et autant je comprends la
position matérialiste qui consiste à
dire que la conscience et le produit de
la matière autant je comprends aussi la
position idéaliste qui consiste à dire
que nous ne sommes que des consciences
incarnées parce que finalement si le
corps et l'esprit sont séparés il n'y a
que deux moments où il est possible de
le vérifier avant notre naissance et
après notre mort c'est à dire des
moments où par définition nous
n'existons pas le drame de l'existence
c'est que c'est une prison que nous
sommes con damnés à ne voir que de
l'intérieur
[Musique]